Russia and the United States continued to blame each other...
...for a near-collision between warships in the East China Sea,...
...with both countries accusing one another of dangerous and unprofessional behavior.
In Britain, Prime Minister Theresa May stepped down as leader of the Conservative Party.
The first round of voting to elect her successor is expected next week.
In Ethiopia, Prime Minister Abiy Ahmed is in Khartoum...
...to mediate talks between Sudan's ruling military council...
...and leaders of the pro-democracy protest movement...
...following a military crackdown that left more than 100 people dead.
In Liberia, demonstrators, predominantly from Liberia's main opposition political parties,...
...have converged at the seat of government of President George Weah...
...to protest corruption, rising inflation and the declining economy.
Finally from the US, US and Mexican officials...
...continued migration talks in Washington as a US tariff threat loomed.